whether to make that you undergo to be
comparative actually the first one is
about public articles about immigration
they're similar in Western Europe and
United States about three quarters of
the population think that immigration is
a big national problem problem and I
should be for sale orchestrated modern
eras run this proportion is actually
higher than other accomplished calçada
confirm this but it's actually much
lower than
immigration particularly the global
south I recall south africa ghana
malaysia so it's in between in terms of
global placement grounds now the next
question will be how does display play
out in electoral politics i was thinkin
versus in place quite well in reporter
primaries i mean its rotation of the
popular is obviously republican
primaries it was a competition to see
who was another in awkward I have no
traditional
formula before unveiling
dimension now we also pays well
exploding other internal feelings in our
ponies
Obama is another one usually stay on the
Mexican border but your honey does not
play well in
and it's in spite of the fact that the
policy of the Republican Party has to do
so much she knows a great quote I was
four years ago
yes I was going to get a lot of the
strategies and this is what he said is
that we have to turn immigrants into the
new games actually its rotational spoke
of a homophobia have been actually quite
a plantation sir and work well for the
Republicans during the use of them for
election day because in many states and
her people came out to both for the
Defense of Marriage Act a new process
border
candidates let
the savvy people
well and they wanted to replace now or
against to focus in the home as
political strategy it didn't work
well now that we know work for several
reasons one is that initial US
population of right-wing populism e
anti-immigrant attributes is one of many
focus and Vanessa Paradis was important
and this is actually quite a traffic
contest to practice again the federal
government that they suspected ankle
bones the sense is sexuality
on gays portion and the urine media
actually over beside him that I think
the upper west side it had a thing of
anti-semitism local website Jewish
working middle America lost that that
purpose I think when he went away
fighting the same thing that cake
holding the attack oh holy used in
respecting converts for the douche
I think now more so this is against the
equation confident the case of you got
home Tommy rhetoric against the
before we discreetly
remember
another problem why doesn't work is a
connection between congressional and cry
in diversity is non-existent now this
was a very very them apart from
exploding it but there is limits to it
actually crank rates of immigrants
emotional too many Americans including
Native Americans and even the countries
are secured
is recognized they continue to be over
so this is not as an explosive as a
splode explodable a vision in a failure
the same thing is to offer greater
regulation we paint to connect
immigration Peter
fear of terrorism in Europe in what's
collection in the United States the
rhetoric of his disposal connection does
not know when you mentioned were cumin
in united states with that we haven't
yet the immediate image that go to be
electric
mine is Mexican information terrorists
there is another there is another girl
image be too difficult to connect report
and they came to spite of the fact that
maybe they may have practical metric to
becoming a better eh another thing that
is different in a stasis also that the
argument that immigrants have used
social services in Europe that are
giving false much water in which were
exploitable the United States is people
to say that Ramirez its exploit or abuse
social services
what we're saying this is party who is
pinging monsters so in that sense he
doesn't work that way another thing that
it was mentioned is that in the end of
Europe immigrants are not only target of
singapore's of racism into our beauty in
the quiet accused right the United
States into google in half because we
have a native underclass poor blacks
right that continue to be the main
tactic of aces and then therefore
the higher racism is just plain source
please mahal and I think this this is
actually a quite important the other
thing is that the reality of
considerations more copies in the United
States is not only related to poverty
there are many different groups who are
most region may contain
the per capita family income of
you're being means is about 20,000
workers hired those white making things
as more some African groups that in also
so it's business more complicated and
then the other thing that is different
is that the food that is this is not at
uni generation of our told to set to
generational group this is a group that
was here before the only we're here
before penises existed so it's a
multi-generational group right not
simply an amino group but that we
penalize politicians politically in this
mofo via an entire being of oil is Gopal
so that's why Republicans already are
peddling back when to stop envidia de
Regina proposal
lucia already a heater I mean ask my
last a my last point here is that a
America's action
much more schizophrenic if you will
about immigration because you generation
is so such a big item national ID equals
four national sophistication there are
actually falling to hundreds of the
world
they who have more immigrants high
proportion of immigrant populations that
United States but none of the
yes the middle of context of immigrant
nation of immigrants is actually oh my
use the national
description the immigrant remaking
american dream in aspiration of
chemicals is very similar to what
Americans think they are he center and
moving on enterprise inc restless people
were looking for a chance an opportunity
they don't one said you remember the
morning are in Spain I will protect them
they just want to chance and that we saw
that it is so I'm giving up fences is
very complicated is is like beautiful
things right the dominant a national
that also is different
you